it doesn't look anything like a police
station but this flat in Rotterdam is on
a Chinese list of overseas missions used
for Consular activities like extending
passports and driver's licenses but also
to do police work extending home Chinese
Nationals accused of committing crimes
but it goes further than that according
to a Spanish Civil Rights group which
says it has evidence that these stations
also spy on dissidents and intimidate
them these tactics include threats and
harassment of family Detention of family
members covered agents all these kind of
stations being involved in tracking
people directly wherever they are around
the world activist Wang Jing Zhu says a
person claiming to work at an overseas
police station in Rotterdam contacted
him earlier this year
and he asked me go to Rotterdam
immediately and he asked me thinking
about my parents and he also asked me to
go back to China solve my problem
who says he's wanted in China for
political activity says he broke off the
contact after he felt threatened Al
Jazeera can't independently verify his
claims the Dutch foreign minister has
ordered the Chinese ambassador to close
the Undeclared Consular stations since
they did not apply for an official
license but China denies the service
centers are illegal police stations
foreign
what I can tell you is that according to
what we know the institutions you
mentioned are not police stations or
Police Service Centers they have
activities are meant to assist local
Chinese citizens on each of the new
expired driving licenses online and
provide Health checkup services
this address is one of 30 listed by a
Chinese website as one of fujo's
overseas police stations but when we
spoke to the daughter of the man accused
of running it she denies any Consular
activities are taking place and she says
there's certainly no intimidation or
harassment coming from this apartment I
just want to say no it's not true I
don't know what people are talking about
and I feel very offended because this is
like happening our private life is like
we don't know what to do because we can
I I don't know what to say because I
only do some first thing for me and for
my family as well in the UK the
government also takes a report very
seriously and they started an
investigation the protection of people
in the United Kingdom is the of the
utmost importance and any attempt to
illegally repatriate any individual will
not be tolerated government
investigators will now have to find
evidence if this is what has been
happening at what China calls its
overseas service centers stepfast in Al
Jazeera in Rotterdam